there's a lot of content in this talk
and you'll see why in a moment i'm not
sure we're going to get through all of
it but i'm going to rattle through it
and you can come and talk to me
afterwards if you need clarification on
anything i talk about i'm going to start
with a quick introduction of ddd domains
from design what is it anyway
then i'm going to move on to some
strategic
ddd topics ubiquitous languages and
bounded contexts then we're going to go
to the other end of the scale and talk
about the smallest parts the smallest
simplest patterns in domain driven
design value objects and entity objects
then we're going to move on to
aggregates which is a topic that some
people find very confusing at first when
they first get into ddd
then i'm going to shift
gears and talk about software
architecture and how the architecture of
an overall application can be centered
on a domain model then if we have time
i'm going to talk about
repositories and domain events so let's
get back to the program
and think about well what is ddd
a bit of a health warning though there
are no answers in software design or
modeling but there are plenty of choices
to make and whenever we design a
software system or design a domain model
it's all about making choices and there
aren't necessarily any right answers so
i'm not going to give you right answers
today
discovering good answers for your
context is something that's very much up
to you
what we've noticed is that
domain-driven design is often
encountered in classic enterprise
computing projects which are nearly all
written in on the jvm stack in java on
the dotnet stack in c sharp
and some of the languages have picked up
quite a big ddd community like f-sharp
for example but we see relatively little
ddd activity in python
which is a shame because python is a
great fit for ddd there's nothing that
is happening in ddd that we cannot
implement in python
domain-driven design is about distilling
a problem domain down to its essence and
python allows us to produce very low
ceremony solutions and so they're
actually excellent fit
to each other
so we're going to talk about how to
bring these things together
and
hopefully you can get inspiration from
this and go away and think about using
ddd in your own projects
so one approach to learning dvd is to go
out and buy the original book by eric
evans which is what 15 years old now
from 2003
it's a very heavy blue book
it's
almost completely indigestible unless
you've already been through a ddd
project
so this is not the right place to learn
ddd
it's a great book to read when you've
been through a couple of ddd projects
ideally one of which has failed
and then you'll understand what eric
evans was talking about
so this is definitely a book that you
will come to in your journey with ddd
but it is not a good starting point
i later in the talk will refer you to
some much better starting points for
getting to grips with ddd
so ddd is it's a philosophy for bringing
software closer to the problem domain we
are coming up with software solutions
that are driven by the problem rather
than driven by technology
by involving domain experts and it's a
systematic approach which involves some
strategic design practices i'm not going
to really talk about those today a bunch
of principles
and some guidelines rules and patterns
which i largely am going to talk about
today
ddd is not about specific technologies
it's very largely technology agnostic
technology is of course important but it
isn't the driver
it's not a heavyweight method it doesn't
imply that we need to do waterfall and
do all of our design up front it's
completely possible to use in an agile
context
and also it's not always appropriate
anybody who stands up at a conference
and tells you that you're doing it wrong
unless
is a charlatan
all the advice you get at software
conferences is context dependent and
there are plenty of context in which ddd
is not appropriate so you should be
aware of the context in which ddd works
well and be prepared to use it in those
contexts but be prepared to search for
other types of solutions in other
contexts
so let's take some pictures from eric
evans the the father of ddd if you like
this is very difficult to read so we'll
zoom in on part of it
actually we'll go back and zoom in on to
this part
so
the practices and patterns of dddd are
really broadly divided into two areas
strategic ddd
which are
have a broader context
they're very influential on how a
project turns out or how a product turns
out but they are not really related to
the kinds of decisions you're making
every day as a programmer as a developer
i'm going to briefly talk about some of
these
particularly bounded context and
ubiquitous language
and then there is tap the tactical ddd
patterns which are these are the things
that as a developer as a programmer
you're dealing with day in day out
you're creating entities you're creating
value objects you're working with
aggregates so these are
um as programmers these are the things
that you'll interact with
much more frequently
so before we get into the tactical
aspects let's just quickly
look through the ubiquitous language and
bounded contexts
so
one definition of domain driven design
by vaughan vernon
is that ddd is primarily about modeling
a ubiquitous language in an explicitly
bounded context now that is actually a
very deep statement
and it makes a lot of sense to me
because i've been doing this for a long
time but i'm going to try and unpack
that for you and what it means
now all domains have
a language which people working in that
domain used to talk about the things in
that domain including ddd
this is a kind of meta ubiquitous
language these are the words we use to
talk about
when i'm giving this talk you'll hear me
words that use like use words like
domain and design and language and
system and context
because this is the ubiquitous language
of ddd but any
domain that you're working in will have
its own language
and the experts working in that domain
will have their own language and one of
the key things we need to do in a ddd
project is to learn that language
and rather than imposing our own
language on the domain take the language
from the problem domain into our
solution
so this is called the ubiquitous
language and ubiquitous meaning to use
everywhere or
being everywhere
so one of the key objectives of ddd is
to create a supple knowledge-rich design
which calls for a versatile shared team
language and that's not just shared
amongst developers that's shared amongst
everybody involved
and lively experimentation with the
language
it takes time to discover a language you
won't get it right first time
you need to experiment and discover and
refine and be prepared to change
decisions you've made earlier
the ubiquitous language is context
dependent if you're doing fighter
aircraft avionics that's going to have a
very different ubiquitous language to
sending out people's utility bills
a ubiquitous language is valid within
a context within a limit of
applicability and that is called the
bounded context i'll come on to that in
a moment she's used by a community of
domain experts as a shared meaning it's
unambiguous it has a single meaning
and it's expressed and this is really
important the language is expressed in
the software model we use those words
when we're writing the software and this
helps reduce the distance between the
problem domain and the solution domain
and because the solution is very close
to the problem any change that happens
in the language the domain will evolve
over time
should
be reflected as a change in the software
as a change in the model
so we need to strive to use the
ubiquitous language when we're naming
things in code when we're naming things
in databases when we're naming things in
tests
a banded context is the limit of
applicability of a ubiquitous language
and many larger domains will have
multiple bounded contexts within them if
you work for an energy trading company
they'll be an energy trading boundary
context but there might be some kind of
systems administration boundary context
where different things are going on
and different languages apply in those
those areas
so
it's very easy to come up with words
which mean different things in different
contexts like the example
i have on the slide and one of the
failure modes of ddd projects for people
who are new to it is that they tried to
model everything as a single grand
unified model
rather than
many smaller models
with narrower
scopes of banded context so when you're
modeling you should definitely exhibit a
bias towards separate smaller models
rather than one grand unified model for
your domain
because if you build a grand unified
model of
the domain the larger domain it will be
sub optimal for everybody
and nobody will have a good time working
with it and you'll spend a lot of time
wondering why the things that are going
on in the real world don't map very
neatly
onto the things that you've
expressed in your software
so
models will exist within bounded context
you should prefer to have multiple
bounded contexts for anything other than
trivial domains
the context is the scope of the language
we have separate segregated models
and independent autonomous
implementations you don't even have to
write them all in python
right maybe another language is
appropriate for some of these models
and ultimately these will these bounded
contexts of language will align with
technical components so if you have if
you identify three bounded contexts in
your domains it's a really good idea to
have three systems
right if you try to map that onto two
systems or four systems you're setting
up yourself for difficulty so ideally
they should align with technical
components and be loosely coupled and
then you're going to have to do some
work
which i'm not going to talk about
further today in context mapping in
terms of how concepts in one domain map
to another and a context map is both a
conceptual thing but ultimately it needs
to be a piece of software that is able
to move information and share
information between these domains
mapping from concepts in one domain to
concepts in another for example you
might have a user in one bounded context
but that might be a customer in another
branded context they are clearly very
related concepts but you might wish to
model them differently
let's go back to the other end and look
at value objects
these are just about the simplest things
that we the simplest pattern
in
tactical domain-driven design
and value objects are used to measure
and describe things in the domain
so we're trying to measure or describe
characteristics like a currency value or
a telephone number
equivalent values are interchangeable we
don't actually care about the identity
of the object
when we're dealing with value objects we
care about the value of the object
they're comparable by value
and they lack an intrinsic identity
if we have a string which contains
someone's name and another string which
contains the same name the fact that
they're equal
is fine the fact that they are actually
different string objects is irrelevant
okay they are a name
they're self-contained and normally
they're encapsulated and owned by
entities which we'll come up to next
it's very good practice to make your
value objects immutable which means the
instances of them can be shared
so we have some really nice value
objects in python already things like
date time and string they are immutable
and shareable
generally speaking though you should
avoid using
neat
value objects like integer or float or
string you should try to build some kind
of domain specific abstraction
around
those types
the reality is is that your
actual problem domain does not have
things in it called string and does not
have things in it called integer
it might have something in it like a
currency amount or an amount of money
or a duration
yeah
so
strive to make them immutable
easy way of doing that is to lean
heavily on the built-in immutable types
in python tuple frozen set straw etc
validate them in the initializer
then do init or then the new
you might be using dunder new here
because you can share instances because
they're immutable
you can do
interning getters with property
remember to override the equality
operator in python 3 i don't think you
any longer need to override the
inequality operator you get that for
free
give them a useful thunder wrapper
think about whether rich comparisons are
necessary to implement for that type
quite often they are
consider preventing mutation by
overriding
dunder set atra to prevent people
mutating the object
and of course always give your types a
useful then destroy and consider a
dunder format as well that's quite often
useful for many of these value types
and use side effect free functions to
produce new values
so if you do need to modify a value
object rather than having a mutating
method on that have a method which
returns a new value object with the
modified value so date time is a good
example of that in the standard library
date time is immutable you can create
new date times by say replacing the
day
with a new number but it doesn't
actually mutate the date time object it
returns you a new date time with it
all the other numbers are the same but
the day is different
so that's a very good uh
approach to follow and consider using
what i call named constructors
so using class methods so that you can
actually it gives you an opportunity to
express the domain language the
ubiquitous language in your class when
you're creating things
and i've also already mentioned
interning with dunder new so here's a
very simple
value object it's an email address this
is quite a naive implementation but it's
uh simple enough to show on a slide
so i have a class method which is a
named constructor so i want to construct
a an email address from string
i have redundant which accepts a local
part and a domain part there are the
parts either side of the at symbol
um
i have a dunder straw and i've done the
wrapper they're not very interesting
i've implemented dunder eq for equality
and then the hash which needs to go
along with dunder eq and i have two
properties
for read-only access to the local part
and the domain part of the email address
and then i have a single method here
replace which allows me to either
replace the local part or the domain
part or both
and notice that it returns a new email
address object
so you can kind of fake mutation if you
like by always returning new objects
so
value objects are very simple to build
in python
the thing is to focus on immutability
and in fact most of your model can be
implemented in terms of value objects
usually it's a very
good place to start
and the reason immutability is so
important is because it makes them so
much easier to reason about and test and
debug because there's essentially no
behavior in them beyond some initial
validation
let's move on to entity objects
which are the the next level of
sophistication
so entities are different because they
represent things that are
distinguishable by
identity even if they are completely
equivalent in value the fact that one of
them is a different instance to another
one is an important thing
the identity needs to be stable
over time so an object an entity object
cannot change its identity
and it needs to be unique within the
bounded context of that particular model
and for entities life cycle is important
it's important when the entity is
created it's important how the entity
evolves over time and it's important
if the entity is deleted that's not
something we often do
or deactivated which is more common is
to say this entity is no longer in use
they're more often mutable although
immutability is always to be preferred
and they tend to be composite they tend
to be made of other entities and value
objects
so in python it's important to
distinguish between creation of an
entity
which only have it happens once for a
particular entity
an instantiation of the entity as an
actual live object in the system you
might register a user with your system
as an entity and that registration only
ever happens once
but that user might be put into a live
python object millions of times over the
lifetime of their interaction with the
system so we need to distinguish between
creation and instantiation
creation needs to happen via a factory
function
which it needs to establish all the
invariants all the things that have to
always be true about an entity
it probably needs to either create or
get hold of a unique id for that entity
from somewhere
you should
i've discovered to my cost you should
really strongly prefer what are called
factless ids not an id that comes from
the domain just cook up an id somehow it
could be an integer it could be a uuid a
good whatever but don't make it some
fact from the real world because things
that you think are immutable in the real
world often aren't
so prefer an internally generated id
and often the factory can just be a
module scope factory function sitting
next to the class
sitting next to the entity class then
during it on the other hand is used for
instantiation of the entity that might
get called many times over the lifetime
of that particular entity but each time
creating a different instance of that
don't do anything it needs to accept all
the i the id and all the state it's
already validated by the factory at this
point so
the then doing it tends to be very
simple it's generally just assigning to
attributes
consider maintaining a version an object
version an entity version within the um
entity
and possibly also an instance id
it is very important that dunder in it
always succeeds because you might be
calling dunder in it when you take an
existing entity out of storage and you
never want that to fail
yeah it needs to be in a in a valid
state
so
i generally use an entity based class
i'm not going to read through this in
detail partly because it's too small on
my screen here
but we have you notice the dunder in it
here
is very straightforward it's just a
signing to
attributes it's not doing any validation
work because we're assuming that
validation work has already been done
elsewhere in the factory
and
nearly everything else that's on here is
machinery to do with version keeping and
a marker for whether the entity has been
discarded and really put beyond use
which is generally a better technique
than actually trying to delete the
entity
that's an abs that's a an abstract based
class which i tend to carry around
something similar like this
um an actual entity here which
subclasses entity this is a customer
um
we call the superclass constructor we
assign an
an
attribute and we have
some getter and set of properties
and notice that the queries and mutators
check the liveness of the entity as this
entity be marked as discarded because if
so this needs to fail
notice that the factory function there
on the right register customer
that gives us an opportunity to express
the domain language again we have two
opportunities to express the domain
language now once in the entity name as
a noun in the class name and once in the
name of the factory function
so it isn't just something like
make entity or sorry make customer we
actually can say
register customer because that's what
we're actually doing that's maybe the
language that's used
in the domain
okay so
at the most basic level domain models
are
constructed from graphs of entities
shown in the rectangles here which own
value objects and the immutable value
objects may be shared
so their entities are identifiable they
have a life cycle they're probably
mutable
and they're composite and the values
measure describe
quantities
they're
equivalent
interchangeable self-contained and
preferably immutable so this is very
simple and
almost any python system whether it's
built using ddd or not
will involve a domain model
something like this
so what ddd brings really is what
happens next when we get to aggregates
so let's look at aggregates
so here's the previous picture again
what is
an aggregate
well
you might look at this and think well
it's just a cluster of closely related
entities
and that's partly true
but it is it's much more than object
clusters
although an aggregate may have more than
one entity
often aggregates will have only one
entity
and there's there are good reasons to
prefer having only one entity
aggregates really are consistency
boundaries
we are going to require that the model
is always consistent within an aggregate
but we are going to allow the model to
be eventually consistent between
aggregates
okay
so it turns out that in your code
aggregates don't really exist you don't
have to write any code for your
aggregate
it's really a convention that you follow
about how you use your entities
so this is a part where people get a bit
confused because we have this very very
important idea the aggregate which isn't
actually reflected as a
class a separate class necessarily
in the code
but this idea of consistency boundaries
is really the most important idea here
you'll notice that every
aggregate
shown in this kind of orange color has
a
one entity which is special that's
called the aggregate root entity and it
is the entity that is responsible for
maintaining consistency within the
aggregate
because it's responsible for maintaining
consistency it is the entity which hosts
mutating commands on that aggregate you
can put mutating commands on the child
entities within the aggregate but then
it gets more awkward to maintain
consistency amongst the other entities
within that aggregate the aggregate is
responsible for maintaining its own
consistency so while it's generally fine
to put query methods on entities
wherever they are in the aggregate i
find it works well to
only put the
mutating command methods
on the root aggregate because then it's
in a good position to maintain
consistency within
the aggregate
notice also that the
root aggregate is special because it is
the target for any in-band references to
that aggregate
we are not allowed to have deep
references
to entities within another aggregate
if we want to refer to a specific sub
entity we must provide enough
information in that conceptual reference
to go to the root aggregate and then
navigate within the aggregate to the
a particular child
okay so
that's a very important idea the inter
aggregate references are to the root
and all into aggregate references are by
root entity id
ideally this opaque
factless id that we talked about a
moment ago this is important because
then i can
instantiate part of my model one
aggregate without having to instantiate
all the other aggregates that it depends
on
okay it's fine to have reg use regular
python references within the aggregate
and it's fine to have the whole
aggregate instantiated simultaneously
but with
between aggregates we need to use
an id
and generally speaking the factory is
responsible for creating a whole
aggregate so it may configure an entity
with particular child entities at the
time it is created
so the factory factories facilitate and
um aggregate creation and allow us to
express the ubiquitous language and they
hide the construction details such as
entity id generation
getting the aggregate boundaries right
is really tricky
and you probably won't get it right
first time
you need to iterate
look for conceptual holes
which can be instantiated
queried and modified independently of
other parts of the model
look for
parts of the model that is useful to do
work on
alone
use the delete rule of thumb i'll come
on to that in a moment
and as i mentioned already we enforce
consistency at all times within an
aggregate but we are going to allow
eventual consistency between aggregates
possibly with asynchronous updates
try to keep aggregates small
many or perhaps most even will
should have only one entity
from a python point of view i find one
module per aggregate is a pretty good
way of organizing things
i might have multiple entity classes
within that if it's a more complex
aggregate or if it's a very complex
aggregate i may end up promoting that
module to be a package in its own right
that's generally how i
find myself organizing the code as i
said already the command method should
be on the aggregate route
with only query methods on the child
entities
it's okay for methods to accept
transient references to other aggregates
as regular python references but you
shouldn't keep hold of those things
it's okay to use them for the purposes
for the lifetime of a single method call
to do some work
but you shouldn't keep hold of those
references
above all you should remember that your
models need to be useful
and not necessarily realistic
i've seen a lot of time wasted on
producing incredible models
of reality which turn out not to be very
useful for the actual problem the system
is solving so try to keep things you
know trying to keep things
as
sim simple but as complex as they need
to be to solve the problem
so i talked about how finding aggregate
boundaries can be tricky i'm going to
show you a quite simple example if you
think of something like trello
kanban board software for that
let's think about
some entities that are involved here we
have a work item in my model here i'm
going to allow work items to independ to
exist independently from the kanban
board on which they are on
we have a board and we have some columns
on the board so we have three entity
types here it's a very simple model
and the board owns some columns and the
columns own some work items maybe
and thinking about how aggregate
boundaries could be here we could do it
this way
but this kind of feels wrong doesn't it
you wouldn't model it like this because
you wouldn't you wouldn't separate the
columns from the boards into different
aggregates because you need to keep
those things consistent with each other
but i've already said that work items
can be allowed to exist separately
this might be okay
i could go for this
but i think the right answer if there is
one is something like this the board and
the column are separate entities but
they live together within the same
aggregate
and work items are their own aggregates
because they're allowed to exist
independently
the trick here is to a simple trick to
follow is to use the delete rule of
thumb
and ask well if i start deleting things
what else necessarily needs to be
deleted so if i delete the whole board
it doesn't make sense for me to keep the
columns around
okay but it might make sense for me to
keep the work items around
okay so the delete rule of thumb is
quite an effective way of getting at
least a first pass stab at
where your aggregate boundaries need to
be
and we would allow our internal
reference within the aggregate there the
board to the column to be a regular
python reference but we'd want to the
columns to know about the work items by
work item id
and of course once i've finished on my
whiteboard
then i might want to make this more
formal but i wouldn't often
make the effort of drawing pictures like
this
any questions and aggregates before i go
on i'm just going to take a couple of
questions now because there's more to
come so yes
i can repeat the question the question
was how prevalent is the use of uml
in domain modeling
my answer to that is the uml is
sees hardly any use in any project
including ddd projects
i would say it's down it's well under 10
percent
okay i have this particular diagram
because it comes from a training course
on a real project would i draw this
probably not
i have worked on projects where we build
uml models
after we've written the code for
documentation
but i would not
recommend
building models like this or and i
certainly wouldn't recommend trying to
generate any code from the model
i think you're just wasting your time
so i mean you know we can still be quite
agile with this and the model will still
need to evolve quite quickly perhaps and
if you're dragging some horrible diagram
behind you while you're doing that
you're just costing money
yeah
to me
that before i start implementing a
project yeah
i need to design it
right for example i'm talking to a
product manager whatever then like he
gave me the specification but then i
found another thing here another thing
there and the original design you know
messed up yeah
so it's like to do this page in the
second
iteration of the project
i i wouldn't overestimate how long it
takes to do some of this stuff i mean i
would go through cycles like this that
last a few days
yeah we're not i'm not talking about
people doing weeks and weeks and weeks
of design here
you know small bounded context small
aggregates you can
work on parts of the system you can
divide the work up
yeah you can delegate to people
so you don't need to have some big
design effort at the front for this to
be a useful technique
yes
for the video
how should i find the borders between
microservices
i am going to mention microservices
in a moment because i'm going to talk
about software architecture now
so can i come back to that shortly
okay
so
let's talk a little bit about software
architecture
um
nothing we've seen here requires
complicated frameworks or proprietary
infrastructure or fancy architectures or
enterprise anything a lot of ddd is
appreciate is associated with the kind
of heavyweight enterprise computing it
doesn't need to be like that at all
um
i find it very interesting the way we
approach building things in the python
community
compared to the way things are built in
other communities in which i've also
been involved
um
i think to some extent we tend to build
models
in spite of
some of the frameworks we have to work
with
and
like i said ddd is a choice and
sometimes using those frameworks is the
right thing to do
but i would also like you to think about
the alternatives and that's really what
this talk is about
it's about getting you to think about
some of the alternative
approaches so this picture here is from
i think the
not the ddd book itself but a shortened
version of it that came out in 2004
and if you look at
what this architecture is about this
layered architecture we have a user
interface which these days tends to live
in the browser we have an application we
have a domain model and we have some
infrastructure databases and
actual computers i guess
and then you match that up against
for example a pyramid web app where we
have some javascript front end in the
browser we have pyramid we got your
model which is maybe implemented in
terms of something like sql alchemy
or a django app
where we have the browser and
the model and we use the django aum
right so
more than 10 years well probably around
10 years ago now in the ddd community
everyone was crazy about using object
relational mapping
technologies to build their morals
i was at a conference in london about
five years ago and eric evans
the man behind ddd came out with this
wonderful phrase
which i just think is fantastic
the object relational mapper takes two
brilliant ideas object-oriented
programming and the relational model and
incapacitates them both and i i think
this is this is very true you end up
making such horrible compromises for
your object model
and your relational model in order to
get them to work nicely together
so
okay this is fine i can stand up here
and rant about the problems of using
object relational mappers or modeling
frameworks but what's the alternative
well
people have been talking about
alternatives for a very long time
bob martin talks about the clean
architecture notice in the middle of
this he has entities and around that use
cases you can think about controllers
um and then look at look what's in the
outside blue ring there we have the ui
on the outside which you would expect
but we also have the database on the
outside which you maybe don't expect we
tend to think of the database as kind of
being in the middle underneath
everything else
they've moved the database to the
outside and it's the cobon another
signatory of the agile manifesto
proposed the hexagonal architecture we
talked about ports and adapters the
application is in the center
but again look at where the database is
it's on the outside
my favorite presentation of this is
jeffrey palamo's onion architecture
again domain model in the center
then we have
domain services application services and
the user interface on the outside but
again infrastructure and the database is
also on the outside
so this approach is called externalizing
the infrastructure
it's um it places the model at the
center
your application is not about databases
right it's about some problems some
domain problem you are solving that
should be the most important thing in
your software the database is just
something you need
to do that it's just a tool
so the alternative to in
expressing your model in terms of
somebody else's framework over which you
have probably little or no control is
just to use plain old python objects
just write some python code and own all
of it
right don't
become beholden to somebody else's
technology if your project is successful
it's going to be around for a long time
it's going to be around for longer than
probably many of the technologies you
might choose to use
so
as a software architect you should think
about that it's a risk
so mitigate the risk and don't depend on
other people's frameworks where you
don't need to so we can have a pure
python domain model
and we can prefer not to build that
domain model in terms of persistence
frameworks
because persistence isn't a domain
concept go and talk to your users about
persistence they won't even know what it
means it doesn't feature in your
ubiquitous language what on earth is it
doing in your domain model
so
i've talked about bounded contexts and a
bias towards separate models
let me just mention how answer the
microservices question so
in terms of microservices
i would draw it like this based on
geoffrey palomo's diagram from a decade
ago and say each of these microservices
represents a bounded context it has it's
self-contained it has its own model
it doesn't care about the other models
it communicates with messages to other
part other bounded contexts okay so
they could be written using different
technologies they can be written using
the same technology but each one is
optimized to a different part of the
greater
domain
does that make sense to answer your
question
yeah okay
good
i really am going to get through 100
slides in 60 minutes
okay so let's think about repositories
so i've said that we need to not build
models
or we should consider not building
models in terms of um
persistence frameworks
that doesn't mean you shouldn't
you know think about your context that
it's a very large number of use cases
where building a crud app using your
favorite object relational mapper is
exactly the right thing to do and i'm
not railing against that i'm just trying
to open your eyes to some of the
alternatives here
but ultimately we do need to store the
data right it's not enough just to hope
that our computer is turned on and never
gets turned off
so we need to have repositories
indicated by the the red circles here
and a repository is somewhere where we
can put an aggregate
and go back and get it later
how do we know which aggregate we want
well it might be
in the simplest way just by its id
maybe it's referred to by another
aggregate
and we have these id references between
aggregates and so one aggregate can go
to a repository for another aggregate
and retrieve it by id or it might be
some more complex
domain specific query
so repositories store aggregates they
retrieve aggregates
we usually have one repository per
aggregate type
and they are an abstraction over the
persistence mechanism and they are very
architecturally significant
so generally we want to better put have
an aggregate that we've instantiated put
it into a repository get hold of one
based on some criteria
and persist changes
to some store whatever that store is
and possibly also remove aggregates from
a repository if they're no longer
required
uh it's very tempting to at this point
get involved in database transactions
and things like that you should resist
that temptation
transactions are something that belongs
in the application layer
not in the domain model the domain model
shouldn't be concerned with database
transactions
why
well go and ask your users whether
database transactions is a thing in
their domain
and how they talk about that in their
domain language and they'll have no idea
what you're talking about so it doesn't
belong in the model
there are many ways of building
repositories we can have what are called
collection oriented repositories
uh in the python sense you can think of
a repository that behaves like a
dictionary where we can retrieve
if you imagine building a class which
has an interface that looks like a
python mapping looks like a dictionary
and we can go and fetch things by id
and how it actually
pulls those from storage is an
implementation detail
so
it's certainly possible to make
dictionary like
repository interfaces
or we can have a more what's called
persistence orientated uh design
where we put an aggregate in we remove
an aggregate
and there's a much more explicit notion
of saving if you like with a persistence
oriented repository there or there are
other repository types as well i'm not
going to talk about event sourcing today
but
that is certainly a
an option here
probably a too popular option
so
collection oriented repositories are
very easy to use but they can be quite
complex to implement because you're
trying to put a kind of dictionary
abstraction on top of some machinery
that might be quite complex
and they're a good fit if you're using
something underneath like sql alchemy
which
can be an intrusive dependency
persistence oriented repositories are
much simpler to implement they're a good
fit with no sql stores like mongodb
but they do require some diligence on
behalf of the application programmer
because you have to remember to actually
save the stuff into the repository
and as i mentioned there are other
options
so generally we will have an abstract
repository
inside the domain model why because
the different aggregates need to be able
to get hold of each other somehow so we
need to have a repository interface in
the domain model but we defer the
implementation of that repository to
outside in the infrastructure layer
and because of that relationship that
dependency inversion repositories need
to be instantiated even further out in
the application layer there's some
pictures coming up that
makes this more evident
uh so you need to consider testability
in fact this is very good for
testability because you can build
fake or very simple in-memory
repositories for testing
testing in your domain model although
not testing your large application
some advice here it's very uh tempting
to thank you it's very tempting to
implement generic selected queries
something like uh like i have on the top
right here like repo
employees with
and then some lambda that says age
greater than 60. that's really nice to
use as a programmer it seems like but
you're not really expressing the domain
language here and also it's very
difficult to implement that in terms of
different repository implementations how
do you convert that language lambda to a
sql query
we have technology to do that but it's
probably not a technology you want to
necessarily get involved in
it's much better to you to
take the opportunity to express the
domain language and have a repository
query method which is something like
uh on the employee's repository
something like eligible for early early
retirement because that's the actual
question that's being asked
okay
so in terms of how i might organize code
for something like this i would
generally have multiple packages i have
an application package
which is the outer layer if you like an
infrastructure package which contains
concrete repositories and then the
a
package per bounded context which
actually contains the domain model so
they have this kind of dependency
relationship so the application depends
on the infrastructure and the
infrastructure depends on the domain
not the domain depending on the
infrastructure so this is the key
dependency inversion in the clean
architecture or the onion architecture
so if you're using something like sql
alchemy this is probably the exact
opposite of what you're doing today
here's another picture superimposed on
the onion
here
so i have
just under 10 minutes left so
let's crack on
and talk briefly about domain events
and
so we've just done like an entire day of
training
right without the exercises um so now
we're on to day two
in the last five minutes
so
let's see how we get on um domain events
and
modelling time so what is a domain event
it's capturing the memory of something
interesting which happens in the domain
right now interesting means interesting
to the domain people not interesting to
software people
right so if your disk fills up right
that's not a domain event it's something
your logging
needs to know about but it's not a
domain event right if a new customer
registers with your system that's a
domain event
okay
so generally speaking um
aggregates will emit events
uh this allows us to model time
explicitly
they're significant to the business
they're first-class members of the
domain model this is something that was
really missed back in 2004 at the
beginnings of ddd
but the tdd has become very
event-centric
recently and of course it's the
foundation of event sourcing and
projections and process managers which
i'm not going to talk about today but
you have to have domain events for these
things to work and they allow us to
establish causality
between things and of course if you have
them they are wonderful for logging
although that's not their
primary purpose
okay
so given the time i'm going to go to
this one so
you should name your events in the past
tense
so money deposited not deposit money
they should be immutable value objects
themselves
why should they be immutable well you
don't want people going around screwing
around and changing the attributes of
something that's just happened
right it needs to be an immutable record
it's good practice to get a time stamp
in there somehow monotonic hopefully
and
include the aggregate root id of the
aggregate that created the event
and any any information required to
navigate to child entities
i generally define my event classes as
nested classes within
the entity
the root entity
and you may consider organizing them in
the same way we do with exception
classes so that you can listen to
particular events based upon the
inheritance hierarchy
and prefer a publish subscribe messaging
system
um
rather than subject observer so
something like python within your
boundary context if your application is
fine you may want to republish those
method those messages to a message bus
for other bounded contexts
to listen to
and act upon but within your single
bounded context it's probably just going
to be quite a simple python application
and you can just use very simple
technologies for that
um i'm not going to talk about that
because i'm going to be out of time
shortly um
i do want to cover this though
descriptive events versus prescriptive
events so it's very tempting to
write methods which modify the model in
some way and then emit an event which
describes what's just happened
that's the kind of natural thing natural
way to write things and you probably do
that
a lot
the problem with that is what you
actually did
and what you just published don't
necessarily match those things can get
out of sync you know you forget to one
of them gets changed you forget to
update the other one and then your
events aren't a reflection of what
actually happened a much better approach
is to
in your command methods which mutate the
model
is to describe the mutation you would
like to make in an event
right and then apply that event
as a way
of mutating your model and then those
things cannot diverge they have to be
the same so
probably last bit of code here
descriptive events on the left
i um
you can see i mutate the
underscore name attribute to the new
value and then i publish an event
the alternative approach in the in the
name setter here i create the event
object and then i do self dot apply
event
okay and that is what actually causes
the mutation to happen
and that dispatches to the function at
the bottom of the screen which actually
does the work
so just to summarize
um we've actually in an hour covered
quite a big chunk of everything in the
ddd book and it will take you a lot more
than an hour to read it i hope you've
had a bit of a flavor
of um
of what's in there
so we've covered domain events entities
value objects aggregates factories
repositories delayed architecture
we haven't covered services
and there are lots of other things which
sit around the dd that aren't on this
diagram like process managers how do we
model long-running processes
that affect the model where the user may
come and go during the course of that
process
uh occurring
so we've uh we've done pretty well in an
hour i think
i'm just going to close on some
[Music]
references for you to go and look at
other things if your if your interest
has been peaked
by what i've said today there is the
blue book remember what i said earlier
it's uh not the best starting point
a very lightweight starting point is
vaughn vernon's book domain driven
design distilled that's about a
centimeter thick the blue book is about
five centimeters five or six centimeters
thick
if you choose to read only one book read
this one
domain driven design sorry implementing
domain driven design by vaughn vernon
and the tweet there has a suggested
approach to reading this book which is
to read chapters one to four
and then go away and try and build
something and come back and use the rest
of the book as a reference